[Musique]
info ou intox ce soir avec antoine
fenaux antoine bonsoir clair on va
revenir avec vous sur un nouvel exemple
de désinformation russe autour de la
guerre en ukraine oui effectivement rien
de rien de bien surprenant vous mesurer
autour d'une femme et d'une ville en
particulier la ville
c'est mario paul la femme son visage
vous dit sûrement quelque chose je vous
la montre juste ici elle s'appelle
marianne avichai vie chère sky à
l'ukrainienne sa photo rappelez vous
avez fait le tour du monde elle était
enceinte dans les ruines de la maternité
de marioupol on voit ici un exemple
d'une photo d'elle en train de descendre
les escaliers de la maternité dévasté
donc enceinte elle avait pu être évacués
et donner naissance à son enfant bien
heureusement on peut voir ici une photo
d'elle justement avec sa fille et bien
mariana figurez-vous clair et bien elle
a donné de ses nouvelles mais bien
entendu vous allez voir qu'il ya un loup
voici une interview que je ne vais pas
vous montrez vous allez comprendre
pourquoi d'une interview une interview
qu'elle a donnée à des chaînes une
chaîne pro russe une chaîne pro kremlin
je n'ai pas vous la montrer car on
suppose ici info ou intox et
observateurs calais elle a pu réaliser
cette interview sous la contrainte
pourquoi eh bien d'abord parce qu'elle a
été diffusée relayée par des comptes pro
russe et celui que je me montre et à
l'instant à l'écran mais aussi par des
comptes des organes officiels également
c'est le cas ici vous le voyez de la
mission russe à genève sur son compte
twitter qui nous détaille les grandes
lignes de ce que contient cette
interview donc d'abord et bien qu'elle
affirme qu'il n'ya marianne a affirmé
qu'il n'y avait pas eu de frappes sur
cette fameuse la maternité de marioupol
et que l'armée ukrainienne donc
notamment occupaient la maternité à ce
moment des propos qui mettent à la puce
à l'oreille bien sûr d'autant que ce
n'est pas la première fois que la russie
change de version sur la maternité
oui absolument et j'ai résumé pour vous
vous allez voir le changement les
nombreux changements de versions de la
russie dans bombardement de marioupol
première étape ça c'était donc juste
lendemain de la du bombardement il n'y a
pas eu de frappe c'est une mise en scène
nos collègues de la sp vous le voyez ici
le résume par un tweet c'était donc le
10 mars ensuite quand l'épreuve des
frappes russe et bien s'accumulent
nouvelle étape cette fois-ci discréditer
mariana la jeune femme enceinte qu'on
avait vu dans les photos avaient fait le
tour du monde c'est l'ambassade de
russie au sri lanka 15 c'est assez
surprenant qui ont été chargés avec un
tweet supprimés depuis mai dont un
internaute a fait la photo il explique
que ce n'est pas une vraie femme
enceinte que l'on voit mais surtout que
c'est une blogueuse mode mode et que
l'hôpital donc été en occuper notamment
par le fameux bataillon azoff vous savez
ces nationalistes ukrainiens alors
effectivement et bien marianne à vichy
remise callas est bel et bien
effectivement elle est bien blogueuses
mode tout à fait j'ai retrouvé ici pour
vous son compte instagram où elle publie
effectivement beaucoup beaucoup de
contenus relatifs donc à la mode
problème est bien elle et de marioupol
donc elle et elle vit dans cette villa
et elle documente sa grossesse notamment
qu'on a vu depuis plusieurs mois j'ai
choisi pour vous une autre photo ici qui
n'a un peu rien à voir mais elle date
d'octobre 2021 elle a été prise à
marioupol et là vous allez voir le
discours us et bien il frôle carrément
l'absurde plusieurs contes russes et
bien eux
affirmé bien que mariana à jouer la
comédie qu'elle a notamment mis mais le
rôle d'une autre femme enceinte vous
savez on avait vu une autre femme
enceinte les images sont un peu un peu
difficile mais vous souvenez de cette
femme qu'on avait vu évidemment vous
enlevez cette photo cette femme qu'on
avait vu sur un brancard et qui était
malheureusement décédé peu après avec
son avec son enfant et bien et bien là
pour la russie bien c'est bien simple
mariana et bien la jouer le rôle de
cette femme enceinte est là elle a fait
semblant donc en résumé je vous résume
la position russe un pas de
bombardements 2 on a bombardé mines
avait pas de femmes enceintes 3 oui il y
avait des femmes enceintes mais elles
ont joué la comédie et enfin et bien
cette vidéo vous avez vu nous les propos
interroge une vidéo qui interpelle
d'autant plus que c'est ce n'est pas la
première fois que la russie utilise ces
méthodes oui absolument et là les vider
la vidéo d'opposants accréditant la tow
la thèse des autorités russes et bien
c'est un classique de la propagande
russe souvenez-vous de la vidéo de ce
journaliste biélorusse on en avait fait
un article ici à france à france 24 peu
après son arrestation et bien vous savez
c'est un avion qui avait été détourné il
avait été arrêté peu après on avait vu
cette vidéo émerger où ils disaient
qu'ils aient bien que tout allait bien
et qu'il collaborait pour la première
fois avec les hits les autorités
biélorusses donc on voit ici qu'il ya
des petites similitudes mais ce n'est
pas la première fois un autre internaute
nuit nous rappelle le cas de cet enfant
syrien omar d'hackney sanglante et mais
en bonne santé je vous rassure après le
bond parent demande à l'ept saison 2016
et bien après la prise de cette ville
par le régime syrien il avait fait une
apparition c'est la photo qu'on voit à
droite à la télévision d'état pour
affirmer comme par hasard que la ville
est bien n'avait pas été bombardés dont
vous le voyez la propagande russe à des
techniques bien rodées avec un but à
chaque fois et bien c'est simple c'est
entretenir le doute sur la véracité des
faits merci beaucoup antoine feu dont on
peut retrouver bien sûr votre chronique
sur notre site internet
www.francebillet.com rester avec nous
sur france24 paris direct continue